I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense would you on this podcast
promote the absence of abuse and murder
to sentient beings by promoting veganism
absolutely what a dramatic intro into
I'd say it for for more than one reason
I mean first of all I really think that
this is one of those things that a
hundred years from now just like we look
back on all sorts of things you say and
I don't believe you a hundred years oh
my god I think the same thing I think
there's no way we're gonna murder right
murder this adorable little pig or this
baby cow and call it a veal and eat it
and steal its milk and tear families
apart and also and also even if you
think that that won't happen there is no
question in my mind and I don't see how
anybody could really disagree with this
but some will that when you look back on
how meat is produced and how chicken is
produced in this I mean yeah we torture
animals and then we eat them so even if
you thought that eating them was okay
and nobody can defend the way that
they're treated and the torture that
they go through you know I I am not all
the way there
but I thought years ago my first step
was well I would never kill an animal
but if it's dead already and on the
Shelf the next worst thing is that it
died for nothing
hey okay that was the first step right
the second step was okay
I now realize that if I buy it I
contribute to the cycle right right I
don't think it tastes bad I have no
problem it's delicious that's not the
problem the problem is ethics and the
problem is you know I did a routine dive
on Instagram in to slaughter videos and
that was shocked
to watch I watched this one video it was
obviously not at a you know mass
production place which would I don't
know if it's worse or not but it was a
cow chained up to the wall the very very
short chain and the dad had a saw and
you couldn't really see what happened
but it alive was standing there and slit
its throat and then as it fell he handed
the saw to his child and I'm like who
can do this and how asleep as a human
being with empathy do you have to be to
do that yeah I mean there's no question
that it Corson's you and it makes you
less aware of the fact that you're
taking life which you are I mean it's
not human life but it's life and and
also the other side of it is I also
think that it's better it's better for
human beings and it's better for the
world right and I there was a Yiddish
writer Isaac West have a singer who is a
vegetarian like 50 60 years ago when
nobody was and he was a won the Nobel
Prize and when he was at the Nobel Prize
thing someone asked him if he did it for
his health and he said no I do it for
the health of the chickens yeah and I
thought they're both true yeah it's I
think that there's no question that
that's I mean no it's clear already the
world is somewhat moving in that
direction but it's going to be a long
and difficult yeah well again and I
understand that sure it's it's an
institution yeah right and just like all
the rest of them they're gonna take a
while to change but i've seen such
positive things about you know the the
dairy you know wall is now half half
plant-based now right that of that's the
other thing science will help because
they'll create burgers from essentially
like a beyond burger I've had beyond
burgers and I've had impossible burgers
yeah yeah yeah they're fine possible
tastes pretty legit yeah the beyond
burger came out with a new recipe and it
is good but it's a little bit more it
you get a little bit more of the feeling
of plant base but they are good now
I I mean I have a standard of keeping
your little ingredients limited and they
do have a little bit more but if you
really look at because I wrote a book
called pretty intense and I it has it's
all health and fitness and mind you
there are recipes in it that have to do
with me because I ate meat back then
more when I very rarely do now but but
it it was really like you know a
difficult you know it's it's it's just a
difficult thing for people to overcome
this it taking I'm and I don't I may
lose the palette and I'm not I'm not I'm
not a judgy yeah no I'm really not when
I go out to dinner with people if they
order meat that's fine with me
I don't I don't tell them you shouldn't
do that I think there's two things I
could help one we should we should limit
the portion size and restaurants well
that's also true right if we just limit
it to like that also trimming our eight
or ten ounces it like that that'd be the
max that would be a lot less dead
animals and then at the extreme you go
while there if you still did kill
animals which they did back in the day
to survive what if we actually had to go
do it ourselves
yeah imagine how many less animals would
be dead then right I don't think that's
gonna happen no I I'm with you on that
I'm with you on that core value and I I
think that it is like you said it's the
empathy seeping into everything yeah I
don't even kill bugs now what's what's
going on with me
[Music]